et pour en parler nous sommes avec
aymeric montville philosophe rédacteur
en chef de la revue la pensée auteurs
julienne assange en danger de mort aux
éditions delga bonsoir monsieur mon bide
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france danger de mort justement on en
parle puisque la défense
insisté sur le risque de suicide un de
julian assange en cas d'extradition vers
les états unis malgré les assurances de
washington sur le sort qui lui serait
réservé pour vous c'est un risque réel
il ya le ce risque là qui est tout à
fait réel en cas d'extradition il faut
aussi parler du risque qu'il y à rester
dans cette prison
si on s'interroge aussi sur celui qui se
dit contre ses conditions de détention
ces conditions de santé le rapporteur de
l'onu sur la torture nouis melzer a
parlé de torture institutionnels
la grande bretagne n'est pas blanche
conclut dans cette dans cette affaire
pour l'instant il me semble que il ya
quelque chose qui complètement
extrajudiciaires et qui préside à tout
ça qu'il est peut-être espérer qu'il n'y
aura pas une
extradition tout de suite c'est qu'il ya
une autre affaire concomitante qui n'a
rien à voir mais qui est arrivé au même
manqué sert de le faire et stein
d'ailleurs le juge marc et soeurs avait
dit nous ne pouvons pas extrader assange
parce que epstein ces suicides en prison
convient que les prisons américaines
sont sans dangereuse où j'ai déjà joué
j'ajouterai pour
ces deux affaires comment vous avez
comme les états unis qui demande quand
même à voir comparaître le prince andrew
ça me laisse un petit espoir du côté du
fait que ça ne se passerait pas aux
états unis mais c'est pas pour ça que
c'est pas dangereux en angleterre pour
l'instant on est on des affrontements
entre puissances de l'otan on a vu avec
la france que être dans l'otan ne ne
présidait pas de ne prédisait pas
forcément que vous avez des bonnes
relations tout le temps au beau fixe la
faire des sous marins australiens on
était un exemple et je crois que c'est
ce qu'il est tout petit peu d'espoir
pour peut-être même trempe et on va voir
dans les semaines qui viennent parce que
malheureusement il ya un accord
d'extradition qui est qui et qui est
essentielle mais à mon avis c'est ça qui
est pour l'instant en brune les
relations entre les états unis et la
grande bretagne c'est quand même la
famille royale qui est impliqué dans la
sphère people vous pensez que cette
affaire évidemment qu'elle est politique
mais ça voudrait dire si on vous suit
que les juges dans cette histoire de son
sort est pas totalement indépendant
devaient aussi examiner si cette
accusation était politique ce qui est
quand même très très drôle ça faisait
partie de leurs des trois réquisits ti
dix ans de cette procédure outre bien
sûr la sauce en état de santé
sa capacité à se défendre
donc évidemment que on peut aussi leur
tournée aussi la même chose vaut en tout
cas je ne veux pas refus d'extradition
est ce que ça pourrait changer selon
vous à combien s'élève le risque
aujourd'hui que la justice
réexamine sa position et on renvoie on
voit j'ai une année sans hésitation est
ce que je vois c'est que les
mobilisations populaires augmente je
vois les images allons donc j'ai les
désinformateurs là bas c'est une forte
mobilisation et je crois que les gens
ont compris qu'il fallait lier la
défense de la liberté d'expression ah je
dirais un combat excuse moi je vais déjà
dire un vieux mot un gros mot
l'anti-impérialisme de la lutte
classique en contre l'otan je pense
qu'il a vous a quelque part de gauche et
puis les gens droit de bonne volonté
c'est à dire en défense de la liberté
d'expression mais en plus le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes puisque
je rappelle que ce qui est scandaleux
c'est pas seulement qu'on le perd c'est
que de plus c'est que ceux qui le
persécutent il a révélé leur crime de
guerre et que ces gens là ne sont pas
ceux qui devrait être sur le banc des
accusés il faut vraiment retourner la
chose et pour ça il faut une révolte
populaire je pense qu'on s'en sortira
dans cette histoire que si on arrive à à
agréger toutes toutes les volontés pour
le pour le faire libérer pour
différentes raisons c'est à dire la
liberté d'expression et la lutte
anti-impérialiste le poids justement de
ce soutien que l'on voit ces
manifestations devant la cour
aujourd'hui ça peut peser dans ce procès
réellement seul en vo mais je crois
aussi que même le contexte de
désagrégement de l'otan ou même des
dirigeants s'en rendre compte
le fait qu' on a l'impression que c'est
une énergie complètement anachronique et
puis qu'il nous pousse à la guerre j'ai
en moi en tant que l'éditeur j'ai été
attaqué par le rapport de l'irsn qui a
un rapport piloté par l'école note le
ministère des armées écrit par quelqu'un
qui était à l'auteur de deux ans
auparavant tout simplement parce que
j'avais rencontrés dans le cas de la
publication d'un livre l'ambassadeur de
chine donc je fais je suis dans une
liste d'agents d'influencé c'est
grotesque bientôt ils vont y mais c'est
la même pour procédure c'est
l'otan singer d'un homme dans nos
politiques intérieures persécute des
citoyens des citoyens qui dément
cependant de l'information il faut que
les gens se rendent compte que tout ça
tout ça c'est la même politique je donne
mon sac et visage est un auteur qui
s'était 44 fois dans sept autres dans
cet ouvrage met tout ça ça participe de
ses ingérences dans notre droit
démocratique du fait que le droit
international et contre considérablement
bafouille comme quand vous voyez que
même l'onu n'est pas respectée alors
qu'ils disent clairement que assange et
torturés c'est le droit international
qui est bafouée ce sont ce sont nos vies
qui sont maltraités par ce système
impérialiste porté par l'otan il faut
dénoncer l'otan il faut lier la
libération de la saint jean à des
manifestations franche et massive contre
cette guerre qui va nous imposer le
notre état-major prétend que ce nous
aurions nous serions dans un un risque
de haute sécurité que nous devrions
préparer des guerres de l'eau
d'intensité mais contre eux qui pourquoi
dont le banc parce
que tout simplement on doit pas révéler
des secrets d'état de pays
il ya cet avis là aussi qu'est ce qu'on
répond ton talent c'est ce qu'il a
révélé des crimes effectivement ces
crimes se tout ce qu'il avait révélée
s'est avéré peu ça n'a jamais été
démenti donc dans ces cas là il faudrait
plutôt s'interroger sur ceux qui ont
commis ces crimes mais comme ce sont eux
qui le persécutent je crois que les
choses étaient très claires merci
beaucoup américaine en ville je rappelle
que vous êtes l'auteur de julian assange
en danger de mort aux éditions des gars
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france